aún sin consensoras delegaciones
presentes en México tendrán que ponerse
de acuerdo en estos puntos principales
una medida clave de la cop 26 en Glasgow
mantener el aumento de las temperaturas
por debajo de 2 grados Celsius o la
reducción del uso del Carbón una
decepción para la Unión Europea que
quería eliminar los combustibles fósiles
en algún momento Tendremos que dejar
atrás todas las discusiones técnicas y
empezar a buscar un terreno político
común y espero que esto ocurra muy
pronto porque nos queda muy poco tiempo
unos 150 países han firmado el
compromiso mundial sobre el metano una
iniciativa para limitar las emisiones de
este gas de efecto invernadero el punto
de fricción en estas negociaciones es el
mecanismo de pérdidas y daños un sistema
de condensación para los países más
pobres las primeras víctimas del cambio
climático
los países del Norte llamados a
financiar este fondo se oponen a los del
sur
vemos esto como una cuestión de Justicia
climática y retrasar la justicia
climática sería una negación de la
justicia
otro tema polémico son los 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales para ayudar
a los países más vulnerables a mitigar y
adaptarse al calentamiento global una
promesa que no han cumplido países ricos
la cuestión de la financiación está
provocando tensiones en las
negociaciones que debían terminar el
viernes lo que llevó a una prórroga de
la con 27 hasta el sábado